[Music]
so here's my question the concept of the
multiverse yeah the concept of
alternative universes
with
alternative
laws of physics is incredibly puzzling
to me
now when you think about the idea that
this could be reality that there could
be other universes with different laws
of physics there could be an infinite
number of these different laws of
physics and different
does that how does that work
okay so that's an excellent question we
think when i say we just the scientific
community physicists who concern
themselves with the very early universe
cosmologists
that the laws of physics as we
experience them are set in the very
earliest stages of the universe and
quantum fluctuations in everything would
be responsible for another universe
having slightly different laws of
physics than ours because the quantum
fluctuations will taken in a slightly
different law of physics direction than
our universe and this would just keep
going
every universe that's born
even if it started out sort of the same
in the very first instant a later
instant when other laws of physics
manifest
could be slightly different and with the
multiverse where there could be pockets
of the universe that are expanding with
no knowledge of any other pockets of the
universe these are essentially
independent universes from one another
and never the twain will meet imagine
you're a ship at sea and you look to the
horizon and that's your whole universe
there to the horizon there's another
ship that has its own horizon and you
declare this is the universe and these
ships don't even see each other okay
you'll only see each other if somehow
you your two horizons can overlap
and we don't know how to do that in our
universe because they're non what's it's
called non-causal all right you can't
you'd have to find some way to tunnel
from one universe to the other in order
to accept access that but that could be
very dangerous because if the laws of
physics are different than the ones you
evolved on then you could just dissolve
into a pile of goo because the charge on
the electron is different and all of
your biochemistry would change so
the difference in laws of physics comes
about because of quantum physics there's
a i want to call it random it's it's
random but predictable
so in other words you can have a
variation in the properties of something
and because of the quantum fluctuations
that exist within it and when that's
happening in the early universe you are
quantum fluctuating the laws of physics
themselves and that's how you get one
universe with a slightly different laws
of physics than the other there could be
a universe where the laws of physics
there will never allow matter to
coalesce you'll never get stars that
would be a lifeless universe as far as
we can think there could be another
universe where you can make stars but
you don't make heavy elements that would
be a universe with stars beautiful night
skies as we have now but no
nothing that we know and love no planets
no life nothing because our ingredients
come from the centers of stars that
explode the manufacturers these the
whole periodic table of elements where
does that come from exploding stars so
you can imagine other universes that are
not our universe there could be
universes way cooler than ours universes
where they formed life way faster than
ours did we didn't have enough
ingredients to make life until we can
make a planet
every time a star blows up and it has
these heavy elements it's not enough the
first round you got to accumulate them
and we're like second or third
generation supernova here in our solar
system and only then you get enough to
have oxygen carbon nitrogen silicon iron
we got enough we got a solid planet so
there's more than one supernova has to
take place before enough elements more
than one generations of supernova yeah
you can add up how much that is and it's
feeding the entire galaxy so meaning a
stars to supernova and then a new star
is to form and then from that correct
correct so you need a couple you need a
few of those generations to get enough
density of non-original star material to
make things like make a whole balls of
planets for example is it possible and
even so it's not very much material as
big as saturn and jupiter are they're
made of mostly gas mostly hydrogen and
helium that were made in the big bang
not made in stars is it possible that
there's something else that could be
invented or created rather when more
generations of supernovas occur that
haven't hasn't happened yet like it took
so many generations for
very interesting so we are the product
of the mixtures of ingredients that are
in this universe so if you rank the
elements in your body the number one
element is hydrogen contained in the
water molecule because we're mostly
water as you may remember from biology
the next most common atom is oxygen from
the water molecule third most is carbon
and we carbon-based life forth most is
nitrogen well wait a minute those are
the top four ingredients in the universe
itself in order sorry not including
helium which is chemically inert you
couldn't use it anyway so it's the top
four chemically active ingredients in
the unit we're made of that so you ask a
brilliant question is there some other
universe that is a different mixture of
other ingredients and they
opportunistically made stuff out of
those other ingredients what would they
be that's a great question i haven't
never thought about that what would a
universe be like if it was mostly
molybdenum
or something picking up pick some
elements pick some random other four set
of elements and see what you can come up
with
you need some chemical activity in it
carbon is highly reactive with other
elements so that's good it's not an
accident they were carbon based we think
other life elsewhere in the universe
would be carbon based because carbon is
plentiful and it bonds in so many
different ways if you're experimenting
with the diversity of life carbon is
your element to do to do that on so this
urge to say let's see if you have
silicon based life you sure because
silicon sits right below carbon on the
periodic table it makes all the same
kinds of molecules you order carbon
dioxide co2 there's silicon dioxide sio2
it makes the same families of molecules
so
sure maybe but there's five times as
much carbon in the universe of silicon
you don't have to appeal to silicon
carbon is there knocking on your door so
for me
what's curious to me is the assertion
that if we have a multiverse and there's
an infinite number of universes that
means there's an infinite combination of
all things that had ever happened ever
that there's another pair of us
having this conversation in another
universe except you're wearing a red
shirt and i'm wearing a whatever i mean
you make tiny changes in what is and say
that's happening in one other universe
somewhere
and people are wondering does this give
you immortality if you exist in this
other universe is that really you if
your entire molecular structure is
identical is that really you and i think
people are overstepping there i don't
think it's really you it's a copy of you
but it's not you and my evidence for
that is if you're a twin you don't wake
up as your twin ever
even though you were molecularly
identical to each other from birth
you're not you don't share each other's
conscience
so one of you is an exact replica of the
other except you're not the same human
beings so i can make an exact replica of
you somewhere else but i don't think
you'll know or care or feel it so this
talk of i will live forever even when
you upload your consciousness do i we
don't understand consciousness enough to
know what makes you you and me me why do
i wake up as me every day and not as you
or as anybody else that's consciousness
can that be carbon copied and poor
carbon copy can that be duplicated and
put somewhere else and that still be you
or you're just making a twin he has a
whole other independent consciousness
that's what keeps me up at night this
concept of different laws of physics is
all from the quantum i think it's going
to keep me up at night too what he says
what are your thoughts on how a
multiverse could actually begin would
each one require big bang and how many
of those would end up with a chuck being
possible yeah so i've actually had a
total rethink about the big bang concept
because first i was taught that that's
the beginning and now it's pretty clear
if you take inflation theory seriously
you should think of the big bang just as
the end of this crazy creative inflation
process in our little part of space when
things calm down enough that you can
make galaxies involve a kneel and a
chuck and other in other places it kind
of keeps going and so even if you have
only one bang but that it keeps going
add infant item you will end up having
many many different regions where it
stops and and you get what we recall a
level one multiverse you know with the
universe so all it takes is ultimately
one bang and if you have each one of
those places where it stops being
actually infinite then no matter how
unlikely it is that you chuck arise
because the particles started out in
exactly the right configurations for
your mom to meet your dad and all of
that the probability wasn't zero because
it happened here and you're rolling the
dice infinitely many times now right so
it's guaranteed uh what i don't know
because i haven't quizzed people is what
are they thinking of when they hear
multiverse and my my sense is they're
thinking it's maybe a parallel universe
that you might be able to to sort of
move between at some distant future time
uh so
is there any truth to the concept of a
parallel universe in the way it's
commonly thought of in the public is
there an evil chuck somewhere except
with a goatee oh you already have a
goatee
is there a clean shaven
you are the evil chuck chuck oh my god
you're a good chuck
oh my god that's right
just think that through
what's incredibly confusing here is that
different people
mean different things when they say
universe and they mean they're talking
about different kinds of
and in fact i remember once very vividly
martin reece had organized the
conference in his house about these
forbidden topics and i heard these are
kind of friends we have that you get
that right you know you get invited for
tea
and you solve the issues of the universe
okay you know this was considered pretty
taboo back then but because martin was
organizing it people still came and
behaved and but i noticed that two
people were arguing about the multiverse
and i realized they're talking past each
other one guy was talking about
what we call the inflationary multiverse
which is just really big space and we
can get back to that another guy was
talking about the quantum multiverse and
they thought they were talking about the
same thing so i felt i have i stood up
and said hey wait a minute aren't there
actually three different no four
different kinds of multiverse that we
should give different names to to not
confuse ourselves so much and then i
wrote that up and and the book you men
mentioned so what i call
first of all our universe right isn't
all of space it's just this part of
space but just to be clear the book that
you're talking about
is uh you you post you posted something
it's online which is a very clean and
clear exposition of the multiple levels
of the multiverse and that's what
we referenced when we included when we
fleshed out our section on the
multiverse in cosmic query so i just
want to be clear that you know you're
not just pulling this out of your ass
this is you you've thought about this
for a long time our universe we mean
what astronomers call our observable
universe there's a spherical region of
space from which light has reaches then
what i call the level one multiverse is
just other parts of space that are so
far away that light hasn't reached us
yet level two multiverse is what you get
if you take seriously alan guth and
andre linde and others
and the theory of inflation that made
our space so big
which says that far far away in the same
space now you have something much more
diverse than you might have thought
where even um the number of different
kind of quirks could be different or the
sort of forces that are there are
different and we can talk about why and
then there's this third kind and that's
what gets more into the parallel
evil feeling thing which has to do with
studying not the big but the very small
studying quantum mechanics you can argue
and people love arguing about that at
physics conferences that our reality
feels like it's splitting out into
parallel branches
and that's the whole if that is true you
can tap into that weirdness by building
quantum computers and then finally
there's the fourth one which is so weird
that almost nobody except myself believe
in it which is the biggest and i think
of all of this is basically russian
dolls they're nested they're all inside
of each other right you start with
our universe many of those that's level
one
many of those that makes level two many
of those makes level three and many of
those makes the ultimate one the the
fourth level okay he says is a new
multiverse created every time we make a
this or that decision so the idea that
the infinite number of
possibilities are not actually
possibilities until we make one of those
possibilities fantastic question about
the level three a reminder about
sound bite go on yeah yeah yeah yeah
sliding doors
movie watch it
basically if you make a snap decision
that you're really torn about right what
ends up happening might come down to the
position of a single little calcium ion
somewhere in some synaptic junction and
where depending on where it is off the
things go and you end up with a
completely different pattern and either
you decide to say yes to that date
and live happily ever after or say no
and do something different right so that
can a micro superposition can get
amplified into something that's so
different macroscopically that this
decoherence thing comes along and makes
these two things really really separate
so in that sense yes when you make a
decision really could have made both
ways you are in a sense according to if
the level three multiverse is real
creating two parallel
realities are equally real and each one
of you is only of course aware of one
outcome and is going to think that's all
that happened oh my god oh
that is crazy i love that that is
awesome
oh my god
oh right now it's somewhere that means
you created another chuck but you're
only this chuck and so that's all you
need
that other guy is actually happy and
he's having fun if the multiverse theory
is true is it possible to travel to
other universes how would it be possible
for us to exist in those universes if
they have different laws of physics
oh that is cool so
cogent theoretical analysis of quantum
physics and general relativity
suggests that there may in fact be a
multiverse we have no data on this right
now so these are ideas at the frontier
of the exploration of physics and if
there is a multiverse it means we are
just one of many other universes all
with different bubbles so each of these
universes would have a it's likely that
they would have a slightly different
laws of physics okay perhaps a different
charge on the electron a different
gravitational constant the gravitational
constant is a term in the equations of
gravity that isaac newton first wrote
down okay and it tells you it's a
measure of how strong gravity is
relative to other forces in the universe
if those are slightly different and you
got a ticket to that universe i'm sorry
sorry for you yeah yeah right things
aren't going to work out very well for
you they will not end well they will not
have universe so you really do need a
universe with the same laws of physics
because the very forces that bond the
molecules and atoms in your body
rely on the values of the laws of
physics that are in our universe right
how many movies have been made in a time
before we ever knew how to make movies
relative to movies made in the era where
we know how to make movies you can do
the numbers it's small yes the spartacus
there's the okay corral three musketeers
yeah
those exactly that type of stuff okay
okay if we are any measure of the
incentives of creating simulations then
they might have some historical
thing but there's way more interesting
things and stories to tell in the era of
simulations that exist post-simulation
and yeah so even if there are some
period pieces that we might be still
most of these would be universes made
after they could simulate themselves
right our movie making habits are any
indication of anything so the chances
are we're not a little offshoot like a
little statistical project we could be
just statistically it's not likely right
because many because we're throwing
darts right and most of the stories
they're going to simulate are going to
be the ones that are in the era of the
time they could simulate themselves so
that still brings us back to we're
probably either the first or we're on
our way to being the next on our way to
being the next that's correct one of
those that's more likely than any other
possibility here wow
and so i'm so i can now rest well at
night so no simulation i'm good i think
i'm real i think you're real i think
we're good well we'll recognize real so
yes
you forgot about that expression you'll
recognize real recognize real there you
go
signing out
[Music]